Eric Voss here with another new rock  stars hot take the new trailer for The  Mandalorian season 3 has one detail that  I spotted that I both love and has me a  little worried when Mando shakes Greek  kargus hand they pass this statue of  ig-11 in the town square of Navarro and  to memorialize ig-11 sacrifice in season  one ig11 has taken his Victorious pose  he has his foot perched on the helmet of  a stormtrooper like Captain freaking  Morgan but then later when possibisla  and his crew dropped from a drop ship  and start laying waste of the place Paws  passes that same statue Mound and there  is no ig-11 part to it just two pieces  of metal sticking up so did the watch  bomb this statue are they attacking  Navarro or just rescuing it from someone  else attacking it either way we're  looking at a Mandalorian Civil War that  seems to be forming the season between  the different warring clans of the  mandalorians that are out there